this mock interview will show you what a
data science interview is like Keith
Galley is an experienced data scientist
and interviewer and in this video he
interviews Kylie Ying Kylie has taught
multiple machine learning courses on our
Channel this is a great video for anyone
currently in the job market for a data
focused role it's also a solid video for
anyone who wants a better understanding
of the machine learning process they
cover topics that include building a
data set for training testing purposes
feature vectorization and model
implementation details consider pausing
after the questions and thinking about
how you would answer them hey what is up
everyone and welcome back to another
video in it I'm going to conduct a full
length data science interview I think
that this video is great for any of you
that are in the process of applying to a
data science or data analytics role and
want to get a sense of what a strong
interview looks like even if you're not
actively applying for a role I think
that this video is also great for anyone
that wants to build a better intuition
of the data science process and the
steps involved in creating machine
learning models in this video I will be
interviewing Kylie Ying Kylie is a
fellow Tech YouTuber who makes content
on topics that include programming
projects python tutorials and lifestyle
vlogging Kylie has both her bachelor's
and master's degrees from MIT and she
has a track record of success in the
interview process receiving offers from
Top tier companies such as meta the
format of the video will be roughly a 45
to 60 Minute technical interview
followed by a breakdown of how that
interview went where both Kylie will be
giving me feedback as the interviewer as
well as I'll be giving her feedback as
their interviewee some important
contacts I have conducted dozens of
interviews when I was a part of the
founding team of Posh Technologies from
roughly the size of just five people to
all the way until we were just under 40
people I participated in most interviews
so I've seen the good I've also seen the
bad the questions that we walk through
in this video are an adaptation of the
style that we used in one of our
interviews for data science candidates
at Posh so I try to make it as real
world as possible
welcome uh how's it going today
good how are you I'm doing pretty well
the weather's not been too bad so I
can't really complain
um
exciting to meet you uh exciting that
you're interviewing for this team great
to meet you too uh we've been uh looking
for you know someone to fill this role
for the past couple weeks and I know
excited by your resume and just excited
to learn more about you and kind of uh
you know walk you through the task that
we'll be uh solving today so I guess to
start off I'm curious you know I read
your resume but
um just tell me a little bit more about
yourself and I guess what you're looking
for in your next opportunity your next
role yeah so I finished my masters and
undergrad from MIT I was doing a lot of
electrical engineering computer science
along with physics and in my next role
I'm just looking for something more
quantitative something intellectually
stimulating
um and you know just somewhere I can
learn a lot so I saw this job and I
thought I'd apply because
based on the job description it just
sounded like everything that I wanted
you know yeah definitely and and
honestly from my experience like we have
a really hard working team we're working
on hard problems exciting problems so
definitely like fits that category I
guess just to break into that a little
bit more like what you just I said a lot
of things computer science uh you know
electrical engineering and physics I
guess what made you kind of study all
these things I guess what uh excited you
about just that you know spread
um I
I wanted to I was I had the super like
I was very interested in Ai and Robotics
and I just really wanted to be able to
just someday create Jarvis like to have
the tools to create Jarvis and uh which
by the way is Tony Stark's superhuman AI
um and so I thought you know with
computer science I would be able to have
the programming the AI part of that but
then also with EE I would be able to
literally build the Iron Man suit which
would be pretty cool
um and then with physics I think it's
just I've always been really curious
about
the evolution of the universe like
what's out there black holes the
galaxies stars all that good stuff and
so when I took a relativity course it
just really blew my mind that there are
all these things that I don't I just
you don't even know that are out there
right like light bends around stars
because of gravity like that's so cool
yeah no definitely it's fascinating like
especially exploring outside of my realm
I don't have that physics experience
that I'll have that kind of uh you know
uh space exploration all of that fun
stuff experience but I am fascinated it
by it as well and also a fun fact I'm
sure you're aware but Tony Stark was
also an MIT grad so you're in good
company there well I wanted to go to MIT
smart
um okay so I guess before we get into
like kind of the real bulk of this
interview I mean I think you kind of hit
on it a bit with that but I'm curious to
just dig into this a bit more so I mean
in the past year or two even just really
like past like six months there's been a
ton of developments in the artificial
intelligence machine learning space I'm
just curious if there's anything that
kind of sticks out to you that you're
particularly excited about and if so
like what that is and what excites you
about that
yeah so I definitely think that what
everyone's talking about right now is
like check EBT right because it's super
disruptive everybody's like Googling how
to write their essays or how to code up
this
you know something script
um which is awesome but I would say that
you know this this AI stuff I mean I'm
super interested in it but more
specifically I think I'm really
interested in reinforcement learning and
um
and just getting a computer to beat
humans at certain things or robotics in
the sense of like self-driving cars I
think that's really interesting being
able to teach a robot how to interact
and basically do what a human would do
um also things like superhuman chess AIS
or superhuman poker AIS I think that's
all really cool because it's
it's beating humans at a game that you
would think you know is only for humans
like chat like uh poker is built on
psychology math and Randomness you would
never expect there to be this like Nash
equilibrium like Optimum solution right
but there is which is really cool yeah
it gets really really interesting when
you combine the psychology element of
the human experience with machines with
AI and I think that from my experience
that's something that's often overlooked
and it kind of bothers me that it's
overlooked because it's so important to
the concept of artificial intelligence
if it's going to be that intelligent so
yeah definitely I think those things are
super exciting awesome uh let's uh
switch gears and I guess to give you a
little bit of context my name is geeth
Cali I'm a senior data scientist uh here
on the team uh so you know the question
that we're going to kind of present is
something that we're actively looking at
um here so this is kind of the task
right now
um
so you're working as a data scientist on
the team here at glitter
um you know our CEO Mr elong tusk
it has been complaining a lot recently
and where social media site may be
similar to something that you might be
aware of but
our CEO has been complaining a lot
recently about the serious bot issue
that's kind of infiltrated our site or
you know he kind of has mentioned has
infiltrated our site and uh become a a
serious issue that we want to look at we
want to you know mitigate and and solve
so you know some things that these
thoughts are causing some issues are you
know they're quickly responding you know
when our CEO posts and you know within a
minute there's you know hundreds of
replies promoting some sort of you know
site some sort of program some sort of
you know money scheme so there's Bots
that are doing these you know quick
postings uh there's you know coordinated
Bots that are all over that you know the
ecosystem that are
sharing propagandist messages and
sharing fake news messages
so that's a little bit of context I
guess before I dive into like you know
some of the specific kind of guided
questions
um
does that make sense uh what I kind of
presented and I guess first off a
question to you just kind of uh this is
you know not really a data science
question but do you have any thoughts on
like other issues you know bots on this
social media site might cause and things
that we should be thinking about you
know when we're investigating this issue
yeah so I definitely think that
obviously Bots are annoying right like
nobody wants to be tagged in a million
things nobody wants their entire
um
uh what's it called notifications to
just be Bots spamming them right and I
also think that Bots take away from the
real conversations that might happen on
this platform so
um to reiterate
um your question is I guess the current
issue that you're trying to solve is
that there are all these bot attacks and
you know immediately after posting
things get really crowded with these
coordinated messages and spam messages
and you're asking like what else yeah
just this is an exploratory question I'm
just curious and you know it's not
really data science it's more platform
driven I'm just curious you know right
pick your brain and see if you have any
other ideas with like potential issues
with having serious you know bot issues
yeah well I mean I just think that it
like
like I think I think Bots are there to
Target A specific group right like all
these money making schemes like do you
really think that they're making money
or is it just trying to scam people and
like I know that especially in a lot of
the crypto world there's a lot of bots
that might
that that might just be links to these
fraudulent sites which end up draining
your wallets or stealing your nfts or I
don't know all these different
um
malicious schemes and so that's
definitely
one reason why like Bots are bad right
because it's not just that it's crowding
things it's also that your users
are literally being the ones scammed off
of and that does not create a good
reputation for your company
yeah definitely I definitely agree and
you know obviously that's what we're
trying to avoid so also I'm going to get
into more guided questions but also like
given this context and just you know
your background as a data scientist uh
you know do you have any any initial
thoughts about the problem anything that
immediately sticks out like that you
would want to investigate about you know
this this high level I guess issue and
we'll dive into you know guided stuff
but I just kind of also want to just
gauge your high level you know thoughts
on on the situation
um by like thoughts on the situation do
you mean just like what my first
thoughts are on how I would tackle this
problem exactly exactly
yeah so I definitely think that with
these Bots you mentioned a few different
things right that it's coordinated that
it seems like they're filling up
immediately after
um a post has been posted
um it seems like
you know there might be links to certain
things or
um certain themes that the attacks are
always about and so I would start maybe
investigating a bunch of these things
and trying to figure out certain
features of these attacks or these spam
messages
that might
be able to for us with certainty say
whether or not this is a spot a spot a
sambot attack yeah
um
and I I also think that you know there
are certain other attributes such as if
they tag a ton of people right or if a
single account posts multiple times or
maybe the account follows a ton of
people but nobody follows them I think
these could all be certain traits of
a Spam bot
um and when you have multiple of these
things in conjunction with one another
then that strengthens the case that this
might be you know spam
um so I think that those are all
different things to consider and maybe
we can train a model based off of that
to classify whether or not a message is
Spam awesome yeah and you're kind of uh
I guess getting ahead of even what I was
I guess planning on asking next but this
is exactly kind of where the discussion
is going and I think
I think because you've already kind of
hit on some of these points I think
maybe it would be nice to kind of drill
down a bit more on okay you know some of
these features that we're talking about
here so what I'm going to do just
because I think it's helpful for both
you know myself as the interviewer as
well as you you know you know
brainstorming and thinking about these
things I'm going to share a Google doc
and let's try to like I guess get some
of this on paper and we might drill into
some of these a bit further and then I'm
going to kind of ask some additional
questions about this process and we can
dive into those aspects okay further so
sounds great I will share it just
through the um
the zoom one sec the zoom chat
oh no no
is that uh can you see the screen yep
um
not on Zoom anymore oh not on Zoom
interesting
in line right now oh yeah there we go
let's try that again I think it's
because I switched uh where it was on
the uh okay the screen I have two
screens open I switched the screen you
know how it is uh so can you see that on
Zoom
yeah cool all right so I guess let's
just start off
um
hello as well I'm going to delete that
quickly
um
what are some features we should
investigate
um
so I I label the question as what are
some features we should investigate you
can kind of interpret that as you will
just basically let's just drill down and
just get some bullet points maybe of
some of the things you just mentioned
just because I think that'll be helpful
for reference throughout
yeah so I definitely think that when you
look at some bot
attacks I think that there's
probably a few main things to look at
but the two that stand out to me are the
content of the specific
um
the specific posts so content of the
post and then as well as the person or
the account that's actually making the
post
so I think in terms of content of the
post these are things such as
um how many people do they tag
how many tags or for example
um timing of the post or words mentioned
in the post
um
what are other things maybe links
Maybe
maybe images
um
let's see what else
when I make a post
I type something send it out maybe tag
well okay by tags I mean accounts tagged
but also I think like keyword tags could
also be another thing to look at okay I
should like hashtags versus accounts
tags yeah yeah that makes sense yeah
yeah hashtags
um
so I think that's that
covers a lot of like what would be in a
post and then the account making the
post we might want to see like how many
followers yep they have uh maybe
the number of accounts following or
followed yep so followers and following
following
um
and I think maybe like looking at a
ratio between that might be a good idea
as well
um say that one more time I missed that
maybe like the ratio between okay the
number of counts that they follow and
then how many followers they actually
have yep um I also think that if you
want to look at the followers Maybe
um who the followers are because for
example if we've already labeled a few
accounts as specific spam accounts then
when we I mean if if one accounts
followers are completely spam accounts
that we've already labeled then
it's very likely that that account
itself is a spam account right so
um are the followers spam accounts
um
and
something else could be
um
like the types of posts that they make
like how repetitive are the posts that
they make
so if the account is posting the same
thing every time
like hey check out my
like yeah YouTube video and the same
link every single time then it's likely
that that's spam right
um
content of account posts
and I think one more thing to consider
could be like for the content of the
post and the account like so I do think
that
you guys have probably a report spam
feature correct yeah yeah we do
okay so I would say like I mean
something that we could do is how many
times has it been reported spam
[Music]
um
or like how many times is something
similar been reported spam but I do
think that is a big indication in terms
of both the content and the account
itself
yeah definitely I think this is a good
definitely a good starting list
um
anything else that you can think of and
maybe kind of think a bit outside the
box here
it doesn't necessarily have to be
outside the box but
um
I guess one thing that I immediately see
is that you know all these things are
very publicly facing I'm just wondering
too you know being the system
administrators here is there anything
else maybe on a more internal level that
we might be able to factor in on the the
Bots
well okay so I do think that one
internal thing would be like this
reported spam yeah definitely I also
think maybe another could be you know
you mentioned earlier that there were
these coordinated attacks so I think if
you see like across like
if you see a spike in the number of
posts being posted within like a five
minute interval or something like that
and the content on all these posts is
somewhat similar like the I don't know
document distance is someone similar or
something then perhaps those would all
be
um
though that could be like a coordinated
attack right
yeah yeah okay yep so like similarity in
amount of posts so if you just see this
massive Spike then basically that might
be some sort of indicator so somehow to
capture that Spike yeah as it is so
maybe all
yeah so maybe I'll add like a separate
category and just be and this could be
like
um
aggregated action
[Music]
uh or aggregated
things
so maybe one of them could just be
similarity
of posts
um in small time frame
[Music]
um something else that
Twitter might have access to or the
platform might have access to uh
okay let's see I have like
well okay so things that are private to
an audience but are public to internal
uh Twitter might be the emails even
email addresses of the account yeah so
that could go under the account making
the post so like email address
um I don't know whether or not you
require all these emails to be verified
but maybe like
maybe if it's
not a common domain or maybe if
um
maybe if like there's a lot of random
letters in the email like the prefix
then those could all point to
um
more spam-like and I think that this
could be a little bit tricky because
you know back in the 2000s we all made
like really dumb email addresses right
uh so I think that this could get a
little tricky but I definitely think
that there are indications of whether or
not something is more spam-like
definitely and I think that you made a
really good point there with domain name
uh just you know for context here too
like uh you know you're more likely to
be able to trust a Gmail address maybe
than a you know random address you've
never heard of so like some sort of
waiting scheme could be interesting here
right uh I guess in a size yeah that's
why I was kind of like hesitant about
that as well was because like for
example
you might have your own domain name
right yeah geethkali.com or something
like that and so your email might be
like info at this rent this like custom
domain name in which case we would want
to make sure that people using that
email address that does not get caught
up in this like spam filter and filter
too harshly that just because of the
email it's considered spam yeah I think
the way that I would look at it and I
think that you're kind of hitting on
this is that
it could be an indie like I think a good
domain address could be an indicator of
like a valid account whereas maybe a bad
one doesn't say that much I think that's
kind of the point you're making yeah
interesting thing just to note about
Gmail just because I've been through
this experience Gmail very much limits
the amount of accounts that you can make
um for a certain IP address so that
definitely would help you know capture
some positive emails because they could
only make so many easily uh cool I think
this is a great list I think the only
other things I might add here is just
like post engagement but I think this
kind of encapsulate is encapsulated in a
lot of the other stuff like you know you
post engagement likes retweets all that
or yeah as well as looking at the the
details of who is liking these things if
it as you mentioned with the followers
if it's always the same spam accounts
that we've identified previously
probably not good engagement not organic
engagement so I think this is a great
list for this portion I think we can
kind of move on to some of the other
questions about the task but we'll keep
this here for reference so I'm going to
go and scroll down a bit on this post
um
the next thing I want to discuss and you
know you can maybe start jotting up some
thoughts on this is like okay we have
all this idea of what we're looking for
I mean a big portion of building let's
say our goal as a team was to build a
model that could identify and
potentially remove these Bots
um you know a big portion in training
that model is having you know a data set
to work with so I think thinking about
the concept of a data set here you know
what might that data set look like and
how would we go about
one sec let me just write this out as I
speak it out
yeah
and then how would you approach
um collecting I guess that data
so kind of an open-ended question but I
think it's a good one to you know start
discussing
yeah
yeah so
um
I guess to first answer this question I
would
kind of look at this first part of this
question like what would a data set to
train models look like okay well so what
exactly are the models that we're trying
to train right and I think that
you know of a lot of the
the models out there
um I think many of them would look very
similar
and I think that
specifically
uh we want some sort of feature Vector
to be able to feed into these models
and that figure Vector well it should
probably summarize all the things that
we just mentioned above right
so
um I think in terms of
so I think
this question also comes down to are we
trying to tag the post specifically like
do we have a model that are detecting
spam posts or spam accounts and those
are two different questions that we're
trying to ask right
yeah actually yeah which I would say in
the context of this question what I was
thinking about was a I think that it's
good to you know thinking about both
because you know one model probably
wouldn't work for the other use case but
I was thinking specifically about bot
accounts and trying to detect those bot
accounts and then you know what the data
set might look like to help train the
model to you know predict and and detect
unknown right you know accounts
okay so if we're trying to specifically
Target these accounts then I might focus
on more of the attributes of the account
making the post that we had listed above
so that so uh the bullet points under
that are such as number of followers
number of accounts
um that follow them
so
count yeah and then
um are the followers also spam accounts
maybe the content of uh the account so
maybe we can look at the last few posts
um how many times this account has been
reported spam the email address of that
account
and
I think that the most basic
thing that we can do is
just feed everything into kind of a
neural net right
um
I'm Gonna Leave This
so
for certain attributes I won't mention
them yet but like a feature Vector for
that might look like a number of
followers
number accounts
or I guess number following that would
be a better way to describe it those are
very
um black and white numbers right so
there's no question about whether or not
we can beat that into a neural net yep
or some other model
um
now this next question are the followers
spam accounts
so
that's kind of this like almost circular
logic so I will maybe leave that off for
now
um the content of the account I will
come back to that and then how many
times it's reported spam so number of
spam reports on this specific account
yeah
um
and then the email address okay so
I think that
this is a good start but obviously it's
not enough so let's talk about maybe
let's go with the email address first
yep
so the thing is in here I would want to
maybe
[Music]
sorry letting the sirens pass
can you hear it anymore I can't hear it
before at all
oh really I never heard of sirens oh
oh okay
um so right now we have three different
things the number of followers number
following and then the number of the
spam uh reports but I also think that
maybe there's some value that we can uh
assign to the email address of whether
or not it's
more spam-like or whether or not it's
safer right
and well I I'm maybe you're gonna get
into this but what might like a simple
or you know model for that look like
right so I think that
I mean okay so a very basic basic basic
model it could just be you have all
these domain names that
like you know of
um that are popular that are common out
there and we would want to get you know
many different countries not just what's
popular here in the US but suppose you
have a bunch of
like domain names that are popular then
this could be a very simple like one
zero like whether or not it has that uh
opposite of prefix that like domain name
in the email address right so like
one for uh Gmail oh
okay
oh you can't see that okay but anyway
one for gmail.com hotmail.com
uh yahoo.com
Etc yeah
um and then zero otherwise yep
so that would be a very basic
value for email now to get into things
that are maybe something a little bit
more complicated
um we could even train a classifier on
just emails right if we had an entire
data set of emails that are
um that are good and bad that are you
know not spam and spam
um we could train a classifier on that
which would spit out a probability or
yeah which is put out a probability of
You Know How likely it is to be spam or
not spam and so maybe certain attributes
of that email address could be in fact
this domain name
uh so maybe we have some sort of
um one hot
encoding system for these so one hot
encoded uh domain name and then
Maybe
can you just quickly explain what a
one-hot encoded domain oh yeah what
would that would look like just so
clarify yeah yeah yeah so uh let's say
that so basically in
zeros and ones to encode a certain value
and so by that what I mean is let's just
take these three Gmail Hotmail and Yahoo
yeah and put them into like a list like
this right so position one would be
Gmail position two is Hotmail and
position three is Yahoo so one hot
encoding for this for like something at
gmail.com this email address would then
be encoded as one zero zero then maybe
something at hotmail.com would be
zero one zero and then something at
yahoo.com would be zero zero one now if
I had something at random dot ABC then
this would actually get encoded to zero
zero zero got it but basically what one
hot encoding is doing is it's trying to
assign a numerical value to something
that is not numerical because our
computers are very good at understanding
numerical values right trying to assign
something numerical to something that is
not
um and it's trying to make it so there's
no association with one another so
something that you might be asking is
why can't we do one
two three four and just call that a day
right that's because this is telling us
okay one is closer to two numerically
than it is to three but it shouldn't
matter in our case because Gmail should
not be closer to Yahoo than Hotmail is
to Yahoo right they're just different
categories they're not more similar or
less similar so that's why we're using
this one hot encoding got it cool
um
and something else that we could do so I
do want to use like the characters in
the email itself yeah for this
classifier
um I'm trying to think of like how I
would do that I might
well also I do think that
if there's a name or
a word yeah in the email it's probably
more likely to not be spam yep right so
I think that maybe like having a list of
common names and common
um
common words yeah
that we could check that again so that
could just be like a zero one binary
encoding for whether or not common names
or words up here
in email and I think this one's also
kind of tricky because I do think that
you have to consider different languages
right and
and so this this would be something to
think about if we were actually building
this model is like we would need to
think about the different languages and
different names in different languages
and stuff like that
um
so
for now what I might do is just this
simple encoding scheme where we just get
a bunch of common address
um domains and then zero or one for that
I think that would suffice for now yep
um
now in terms of this now let's go back
to this like content that the account is
posting
so
I do think it makes sense to not scrape
the entire like Post history of the
account because I think that would that
might be excessive like I think if it's
a true spam account then like the first
five or ten should suffice
right so I think what we could do is in
here have certain
features for like post number one yeah
post number two
Etc to post number let's say we do 10.
yep
and now scrolling down a little bit
um
the indent all of this
why did it make a bullet list what was
it a bullet list I guess some of it was
no but I I made it I did that nice yeah
um just for organization yeah I
appreciate organization
yeah
so this is basic including
something
more complex would be this okay so now
let's think about the posts
so with the posts
um that would be a lot of this stuff
from up here which I'm just going to
copy and paste down here
Okay so
the first one could be accounts
tag okay what are the simple ones the
simple ones are things such as
um how many times
number of spam reports for that specific
post yep
um
Maybe
okay the time timing of posts I think
that can be easily converted to uh like
an Epoch value or something
um and the only reason why I want to
consider the timing of the post is
because
if for example the last 10 posts were
posted within like one second of each
other yeah that probably indicates a
Spam bot right
um so that's the only reason why I want
to consider this timing and I think that
it would make sense to maybe use some
sort of integer representation so maybe
like seconds or milliseconds since Epoch
um
like
so yeah
uh and then next I would think about
and just uh just because you know with
our team we have to communicate these
things to you know business stakeholders
that sometimes don't understand some of
these details could you just kind of a
very I guess simple terms what is it
mean milliseconds since epoch
it's like I think it's January 1st at
midnight on in 1970 or something like
that
um but you can think of it as literally
just like number of seconds or number of
milliseconds since a certain time period
like 30 no 50 oh man 50 years ago yeah
um
yeah so it's basically
discretizing time such that we can
measure it as an integer
yep
um okay so then next I think we have to
think about all these tags and the
content in the post right
um I do think that
one easy thing to do could be like for
the words mentioned in the post
uh to have some sort of
again like one hot encoding for very
common spam words yeah so so just like
um claim free uh
can't think of all the ones but yeah
yeah yeah I'm not I'm not a Spam bot
yeah but that's good that's good we're
not hiring spam Bots right now so yeah
so maybe like a one hot encoding of
common spam words
cool
um
and I think that maybe this could also
be similar for like the hashtags as well
but
I think that this could Encompass the
hashtag right because if we're just
looking for whether or not these words
appear in the entire string of of words
then like that would cover the hashtags
as well cool and I think honestly I'm
just looking at the time here I I do
want to kind of switch gears a bit I
think this is a good you know high level
description of it implementation I do
want to just ask some kind of follow-up
questions to these things yeah so I
guess just circling back first I think
that really you dove into the details of
implementation I think that this is a
solid approach using this feature
vectorization approach and kind of you
know I think you did a good job
explaining some of these details but I
do want to revisit kind of the uh one of
the initial questions which was you know
we have this way of building this model
with these feature vectors but you know
at the end of the day we need to train
these models and we need a data set to
train these on so I guess I just really
want to drill down specifically on that
like what would the data set that we
need to use this approach maybe look
like and just any I guess thoughts on
that and I'm going to just break this
apart real quick and just say
um implementation approach or something
like that
to separate it a little bit visually
does that make sense what I'm asking
yeah yeah so you're just asking like how
would I collect that data yeah the data
that I just described well well yeah so
I guess what I'm thinking about is the
data you just described I think is
fairly straightforward to collect but at
the end of the day we need a I guess the
two questions I want to drill down on is
what makes an account a human and what
makes an account a bot like how do you
I guess get data on bot accounts and
bought and maybe human accounts like
because at the other day we need that to
make this a meaningful model
right so I do think that
um
well okay so at the end of the day who
is the person who can distinguish the
bot right it's humans it's humans
because when we get annoyed at seeing
spam or something like that like that's
when that's that's what makes
that's what literally makes this a Spam
post it's once some human it decides I
don't want to see this content and this
is spam
so I actually think that one of these
things that I kept mentioning which was
how many times has this been recorded
spam I actually think that that could be
our label right for whether or not
the account is Spam or not yeah so
um
this
this is how we can label spam because at
the end of the day this is a this is a
classification problem it's is it spam
or is it not spam
um
and what our data is collecting is we're
collecting all of these features
but then we need a label for that
feature right and
that label we want two different
categories is it spam or is it not spam
yeah
um
and obviously the more time something
has been reported spam the more likely
it is to be under category one yeah
right so
I think one of the most basic ways to do
this uh could just be if it's reported
spam over blank number of times then
make that like
then label that as spam
so naive labeling system could be
reported spam
X number of times
then label spam
and this X
this is really up to
like what you're like how much data do
you want to collect right because you
don't really want to kind of fake that
data because you know as I was trying to
come up with these things down here it's
it's pretty hard to fake being spam if
you're not spam yourself yeah
um
and then for the non-spam I would just
do like if no reports of spam then uh
label as not skin and also I think that
these no reports and this reports fam
like I think that you should put some
sort of time
frame on this so like since account
creation uh
for longer than a week or something like
that if it's never been reported spam or
if it has been reported spam then I
think that can give you a good
um
indication or maybe not a week you would
have to set the threshold right yeah but
you don't want like a brand new account
to be part of this system
definitely makes sense okay I I you know
I think this makes sense as a naive
labeling system you know my big concern
is here it is like I guess what are the
problems potentially with this approach
like you know how could we build this
make this more robust I guess either you
know maybe identify what could
potentially be a problem here or
potentially just mention an idea or two
about how could we make this more robust
yeah so I definitely think that this is
relying a lot on user feedback right
it's relying a lot on whether or not
somebody has reported something as spam
yeah
um
I do think
like
I mean okay so one
slow but
sure way that you could label uh certain
things a Spam or not spam is that you
could just have like
like you could just hire people to go
through different posts and different
accounts and say oh this one is Spam
like we should use this as
um a Spam account to model
to model after
or to include in our data set sorry
but that would then be also kind of
tedious slow
um you would have to pay more just to
collect data that you already have
um another system might be
hmm
um
sorry let me think for a second no
problem
so I really I do think that this like
this reporting spam is a good indication
because it's similar to how like waves
works yeah right how like
oh is there
well okay one thing that you could do is
you could just Implement something that
makes it more incentivized for user to
correctly label things as spam or not
um so for example
uh you could have a larger
an easier system of reporting spam or
um you could have
literally a direct question of whether
or not something is Spam or not yeah
um
because I do think user feedback is
probably one of the most important
because after all you're building a
product for your users right and like
their feedback their classification of
whether or not something is Spam or not
that's going to be what's important
um
so
maybe like if there's some
in like maybe we can
start tracking some of these things and
just coming up with something naive like
things that are obvious as spam accounts
um if those specific attributes pop up
then we could automatically just be like
oh do we think that this would be
spam like you could have a poll that
presents to the the user that would make
it easier to label a Spam or not
yeah
um I think I think that that suffice
because that kind of answers my question
I think the only details that I would
add from my end here is that you got to
keep in mind that there's a lot of
trolls on social media a lot of people
that are Bad actors and when we're
designing a system like this we need to
keep that in mind there might be
targeted attacks people labeling someone
they don't like as spam so we also need
to factor that in and so that would be
one component I would add here another
thing I would just quickly mention too
is I I don't think it's actually a bad
thing to do a little bit of human
annotation I think a lot of you know
tasks sometimes require that I think the
important thing is we want to
cross-reference our annotations because
we might be paying a group we might not
be monitoring them super closely so we
want to make sure that they are not just
taking a random box so you know
something just think about right there
right cool well I also do you want to
add one more thing to this is like maybe
your threshold should not be like number
of times but maybe it should be like
ratio of like spam reports to engagement
or something like that right yeah
um because even if there are many Bad
actors I do think that most people
uh would act the way that you yeah would
think that they act so I think like
there can't there probably aren't more
than like 10 or 20 percent like people
who would deviate from that expectation
so for example if like I think that's
that's the importance of this threshold
right that's the importance of saying
well how strict do I want to be such
that
um like do I want the the stricter I am
with this threshold the more confident I
am that this has to be spam yeah right
and so that's that's the importance of
this labeling system is how strict do
you want to be because the stricter you
are the less data you have to train on
is another consideration yeah okay that
yeah that makes sense and I I think that
that ratio idea is an interesting idea
and you know the only really way to know
is to actually try this out test it so
it's hard to know with certainty but I
think the important thing is having
these different ideas that are worth
playing around with and uh attempting
okay uh I'm gonna ask one just because
we're running uh up on time I'm going to
ask I think maybe just one last question
on this problem I'm going to stop
sharing the screen you don't have to use
the document anymore we can kind of just
chat about this I'm just you know from a
you know let's start thinking a little
bit more about implementation of this
um you know thinking about Python and
maybe the larger Cloud ecosystem like
you do kind of have a high level feel of
how you might approach the actual
technical implementation of you know
building this model
or anything that keeps comes to mind so
maybe certain libraries certain uh
Frameworks certain just like Cloud
resources Etc I'm just curious you know
from a implementation standpoint
anything that kind of sticks out that
you know you'd probably do from approach
yeah so I would definitely say I'm
probably the most familiar with like
tensorflow so a lot of
um how I would be modeling this is I
would probably start with my data set
and then I would probably go into like a
Jupiter notebook or
um a collab notebook and I would try to
mess around with it just to see you know
what what is the simplest model that I
can make to to have some sort of
okay-ish
um
classification rate right and a few
things that you could use in order to
figure out how well your model is
training like it depends on how
important to you
false positives or false negatives
are right
um
and
like more so than accuracy like I think
those are things that you should be
looking at and also I think that
um
yeah anyway sorry to get back to your
original question is that's how I would
start this and then in order to deploy
this I'm actually not that familiar with
deploying uh certain models but I would
assume that you use some sort of like uh
GPU to accelerate the training and then
um or yeah sorry this is during still
the training phase but maybe you're
training a much larger model than the
initial one that we came up with in our
notebooks yeah so you would use like GPU
some other resources to train it to
accelerate that training process you
would parallelize
um
and then when you actually deploy it I
mean everybody uses like Cloud
technology these days so I I feel like I
just deploy it to some
Cloud that serves the model and
um
and every single time we have a new post
we can just filter it through
or not a new post but maybe
um some new account that's flagged or I
don't know something like that we can
just go through this model and say oh
this might be a Spam account
yeah would we want to do it a single
post or would we want to like
I I guess I'm just trying to think about
that detail as like you know each post
goes through this or is any other things
that we might want to do here
well so the way that we implemented this
it would be the specific accounts okay
right
um so I I do think that you would maybe
wait for an account to have
a few posts but then
well so how I think the tricky part is
how do you catch a Spam account before
it posts any spam
right and so the way that we've set this
up it's it's to kind of go through
existing users and label them as fam or
not
I do think it could be interesting for a
future model to to maybe assess the
first
post that an account makes and determine
whether or not it's a spam
uh Post Yeah and then from there you
know if it's if it determines that it's
not and there's no way like maybe these
newer accounts should just be ones that
you keep monitoring for a while and you
keep reassessing whereas older
I guess you would say Legacy accounts
might have
um
might have more lenience right
yeah unless maybe a ton of people start
flagging it yeah but uh but hopefully
our hopefully our other implementation
would be able to catch that yeah that I
think that makes sense to me cool I
think that's all I have on this prompt
uh this was an enjoyable discussion uh I
think you know it's interesting to think
about I think there's a lot of different
Avenues you can go so right I know we're
running up on time I do want to just I
guess quickly pause and uh just see if
you have any questions for me before we
kind of conclude this uh interview
yeah definitely so I'm just wondering
um like what are your favorite and least
favorite aspects of you know your role
as a data scientist at this company so
far yes I think the big one is I
mentioned it at the start of the
interview is just
um the team the team is really
impressive you know it's a diverse set
of backgrounds both people you know PhD
type people from Harvard MIT but also
just some really really brilliant
self-educated kind of just learned the
stuff on their own bring a different
perspective to the table people that are
on this team so you know from my
perspective you know one of my biggest
goals you know in this role is I want to
continue to grow I want to continue to
develop you know certain skills that I
have like I come from a natural language
processing background you know I can
apply those skills but I don't have as
much of that systems background I don't
know how to you know deploy this on a
production scale so you know what I
enjoy
um you know most I think about this role
is just the opportunity to gain you know
those insights to learn from people that
have expertise and skill sets I don't
because I think that that is helping me
become a more rail rounded
um you know member of the team I guess
on a separate note like that's very much
like team based but also there's just a
lot of flexibility to move around in the
role like I've kind of stepped into more
of a managerial type role recently
whereas I very much was more of an
individual contributor writing code you
know on the front lines previously so I
like that too uh on the flip side I
think at least uh what I enjoy at least
uh you know this is I guess love hate
relationship but you know work here is a
bit of a grind like we work hard hours
we you know it's uh you know to be
classic and cliche you know Work Hard
Play Hard wait sorry yeah Work Hard Play
Hard that's the saying
um so I mean it's
uh we put a lot of hours in there's late
nights sometimes but I think with that
you you do get that learning but it's
just like sometimes it's a balance it's
like just making sure you know when to
step back and and reassess and just like
not get too burnt out so uh love hate
relationship on that side but I think
that overall I would take that over not
being challenged yeah okay
awesome
um and how long have you been working
there so far uh I think this is my fifth
year so you know it's been a little
while so you know I've yeah because I've
had the ability to kind of switch around
my role I think I've
stayed
kind of engaged and yeah I've just had
opportunities to learn different stuff
and I think that's kind of what has
helped me stay this long right yeah yeah
awesome because my follow-up question
was going to be like what opportunities
for growth are there like within the
company and how how does the company
support that growth yeah
yeah
um
I mean there's a couple things I think
just in general from from being in a
team environment where there's a lot of
just driven people that want to know the
latest you know the state of the art
like sometimes it just naturally kind of
comes out during lunch discussions and
whatnot some people are working remotely
some are at you know the office but you
know both channels like you know if I'm
at the office we go out and you know
some of this just the discussions just
happen naturally you know at lunch or we
sometimes host remote kind of like you
know Zoom lunches where we all kind of
just hang out and you know chat about
things so that's like kind of an
informal way from a formal perspective
like
we try to you know make sure that
everyone that's here is Happy uh we you
know have routine
um you know performance kind of
check-ins and perform like I don't I
don't say performance as a like you know
very strict like if you don't meet
certain bar you're out but it's very
much a constructive process where
everyone on the team no matter who you
are whether you're you know the CEO or
if you're you know a junior engineer
like everyone has performance reviews
someone on the team is tasked with
evaluating and having that conversation
what you're doing well what could be
improved so there's like constructive
feedback across the board and we try to
do that
um awesome either every quarter or every
other quarter typically every quarter we
try to have something yeah sometimes
it's more formal sometimes a little bit
less formal but everyone's critiquing
everyone no matter if you're the you
know CEO uh or you know you're more
Junior
awesome
um and then for my final question just
how like what what would my first maybe
six months kind of look like what would
uh be some of the projects that I'm
working on look like yeah
so I mean I think one of the most
important things from my perspective for
anyone joining the team is we don't want
to have new team members be siled we
want to make sure that they are exposed
to what we have kind of out there on not
just my team but you know surrounding
teams so a couple of things that you'll
be kind of doing is first off you'll be
you know assigned immediately upon
arriving a mentor that can kind of help
guide you and
um you know you'll specifically like
this is a role for you know my team so
like they would be kind of introducing
you to our systems walking you through
the code base you know introducing you
to the other people on the team so one
of the big things is like you have this
Mentor that's kind of there to guide you
everywhere every step but another
important point is like we try to make
sure you get one-on-ones with everyone
on the team within the first month
approximately at least within our small
team so like you get to meet everyone on
the team you get introduce the code base
so it's really just kind of getting
warmed up getting comfortable seeing
things yeah probably you know
end of month one to like you know month
three a big part of it will be you know
tackling some kind of more entry level
tickets on the systems really get your
hands dirty plug in and and you know
they won't be the most complex you won't
be designing a system from scratch but
taking our existing systems you know
ironing out some bugs all that get more
comfortable right uh after that you'll
be kind of more potentially leading not
leading but like kind of help co-lead
certain initiatives yeah and that has a
little bit more flexibility you can kind
of get different ways whether you want
to be really the one grinding out the
code or you want to be more thinking
about the design and all that and I
think the only other thing is like kind
of throughout this process we try to
also introduce you to some of the teams
that we work closely with so you'll
definitely have some interaction with
them but that does that answer your
question
yeah for sure yeah awesome well I don't
have any other questions awesome so I
think next steps from here is there's
going to be a software engineering uh
interview so that will test more your
python skills and then also
um
likely it would be like a behavioral
interview as well where uh just great
engage a little bit more of your career
interest and all that so next steps
you'll hear back with us in the next few
days probably and we'll go from there
okay awesome well thank you so much for
taking the time
yeah it was a pleasure and uh nice
meeting you and enjoy the rest of the
day
yeah you too thank you see ya bye
all right end interview I'm not Keith
Cali anymore I'm Keith galley
you put me on the spot answering uh some
of those questions at the end I had to
tap into my uh intro to acting skills to
like fill it but I mean honestly I feel
like I could answer it how I would
answer it if I was in that situation and
kind of from prior career experience but
I yeah guess what were you saying well I
feel like a critical part of interviews
is asking questions to look engaged and
uh and like genuinely interested in the
role right so I didn't want to be like
yeah yeah yeah though that's fair and
the reason I asked that is because that
is an important point so I I just I
wasn't I guess preparing to be on my
toes and like getting ready to answer
these but I think it was good that you
did ask those questions and I think one
thing that might be interesting is for
you to like evaluate kind of my
breakdown my responses and stuff and
what you're looking for because I think
one thing that I think about in these
interview settings and one thing I think
is important to keep in mind is like I
very much it's an interview for you but
I'm very much also like you're
interviewing me and like for me when I
was doing a lot of these interviews like
I definitely got stressed out when I was
interviewing certain people that I knew
were like high level we really wanted to
land this person so I feel like uh like
keeping that in mind as an interviewee
that like you know this is not a one
directional thing like they're like I
had nerves you know going into this even
though this is a mock interview because
like I wanted to ask the right questions
I wanted to get the conversation
patients doing the right way and like
that's definitely how I felt in real
world situations as well where it's like
it's definitely both directions
especially if you really are looking to
land a top candidate yeah so I
definitely think that like overall I
mean I enjoyed the interview I thought
it was pretty like conceptual which is
good I don't like when a lot of it's
just memorization yeah
um and I think that in terms of the
questions well okay to be honest I
wasn't like 100 listening that much
because it's not a real company yeah um
but I do think that
I do think that being like concise and
your answer is probably uh something
good to practice so I do feel like
um you did talk about a lot of things
where you could have just said well I
think your favorite thing is this
because I have a lot of flexibility and
like I have a lot of growth
opportunities and uh that's really
helped me Propel my career whereas a
negative is just that I feel like you
know work is kind of a grind sometimes
but like
but we're all here because we're really
passionate about the product and so like
we're always like we want this to work
and succeed and I want to be a part of
that team so like we work hard to make
that happen just like being more concise
with those responses
um and I feel like you know I feel like
when I ask these questions it's a lot of
times me evaluating whether or not it's
been somewhere I'd want to work right so
like if somebody does say like oh the
work is a grind then it might like that
is probably one thing that I'm
prioritizing is that like I want a
work-life balance or yeah
um so I guess like as an interview or
something tricky that you could do is
like before
asking before being like Oh do you have
any questions
to kind of get a feel for what they're
looking for and then yeah your response
to that but also at the same time I feel
like then it's not very
like as an interviewee I want people to
be honest and genuine with their answers
right like I want to be able to evaluate
for myself like
like oh I I'm gonna expect to work nine
to six every day and then have the rest
of my time I'm gonna expect maybe once
every once in a while to have to be on
call
but not every night and if then the
reality is different from that then I
would be very disappointed right yeah um
and I would want to leave and so I think
that those are things to think about but
I do think like honesty is the best
policy
yeah
um this is interesting because in all
the interviews I did I never really got
the chance to ask that type of question
of like you know evaluate my own
responses and trying to impress a
candidate yeah well I definitely think
uh one thing is like even when you're
interviewing uh you think you like add a
lot of fluff and things so I think that
for example when you ask me things like
oh did you get the question like you
didn't even ask a question yeah at that
point when you were like detailing the
problem
and I think maybe just adding more
breaks in between kind of your monologue
in a way like just being like oh does
that make sense to give the interviewer
you know some more engagement also a
chance to ask questions is probably good
and I don't think you have to rephrase
something multiple times like when you
ask what are some features that we
should investigate regarding the bot
issue just ask that and then if they
have any questions they'll like ask
specifics right
yep that makes sense and I feel like I
goofed there I definitely even in my
notes I kind of wanted to pause and just
like see if you understood the like
overall I guess like foundation of the
the it wasn't a question that was the
issue I specifically didn't write
question there like the premise of like
the context of the uh the problem
context I guess that was it there was no
like question yet but I even though I
wrote in my notes that I fixed I removed
question it just did like problem
context I think I said it out loud again
so it's like good to know I think it's
good to know to not be too fluffy I
think I like doing that
um so this is good insights from my
perspective I do want to just like as
part of the uh video also like give you
some feedback I guess last question
before I do that is like
I guess any other feedback on I guess
the premise of the question and like
just the flow of that type of interview
um
no I do think this was a very
interesting interview because it's not
straightforward right it's not like I
can just mention the various features
that I would put into a model like I do
think that it required some time to
think about
um I do think it was very open-ended and
I think that's good in some ways because
it forces
me at the interviewee to ask for
specifics and
um and you can you can tell a lot about
a candidate by the questions that they
do ask and I also think that for example
when I was trying to go through you know
what would this data set look like or
how would you approach collecting that
data like I do think that
um the one tricky part that I kind of
faced was after I did this like naive
labeling system you're like well what is
what is wrong with that and in my head
I'm like well obviously you can do
something more complex but like I think
as a baseline like there's nothing wrong
with like what I said right because it
just depends on where you set that
threshold so I would actually unless an
interview interviewee is like blatantly
wrong I think from the perspective of an
interviewee like I don't like I'm also
under stress right like I don't want to
just
I don't want to hear like oh that's
wrong yeah
um
you did say it was like wrong but you
just said oh there might be some flaws
with that like
like can you think of anything and so I
tried my best to think of some things
but I do think that like maybe if you
had said well this you know user
feedback is really great but can you
think of anything specifically with like
this specific part of that that
things might go wrong or something like
that yeah I think the ish the challenge
is a balancing act it's like on the one
hand I don't want to be leading I don't
want to like be like hey you could think
about this specific thing so I try to
like I think maybe I could be more
positive instead of saying what's wrong
you know just saying how can you improve
this and just leaving it at that
I think that would also be good because
I think when you said like
like there are some flaws here it made
me think like oh this system is just
like yeah like I should just not be
using
um like reports of spam but like I think
that you genuinely should be using
reports of spam if you're trying to
label your data right so I think like I
think if you had asked like oh what's a
way to improve upon the system that
would make me think okay I'm on the
right track but yeah what are some flaws
that I can think about there
yeah I definitely agree with that I
think just one note to add to I think
that from an interview's perspective I
think that that's the best approach that
you what you mentioned from your
perspective one thing that you could
potentially employ and whether or not
you want to do this it's kind of up to
you I've seen this before in real
interviews that I've done is like you're
welcome to push back at that if you do
it in like a you know a
I don't friendly is maybe not the way
but like in a professional way and say
actually I think that this is a fine
like I don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with this I think this
is a good Baseline approach we can
improve it like you can kind of spin it
that way too obviously with nerves and
stuff it's tough to do that but like
I've been at an interview where we like
we kind of got into a debate but in that
I learned a lot about how they think
that they're willing to stand up for
what they believe in and like they
weren't ever aggressive but they were
able to like stand their ground argue
their points but be willing to listen to
my side and like kind of we could come
to an agreement so whether or not you
want to play into that you know is up to
you sometimes interviewers might be
cruel and they might purposely get your
nerves and be like make you think you're
doing something wrong even though you're
not but uh yeah it's an interesting I
think from both sides the right you know
it's a chess match a bit there
um yeah no I agree
okay I don't have anything else yeah so
from my perspective just to add some
details I guess I mean overall like
I mean some high level things like the
reason that I would approach an
interview like this
is because if this is like a high level
position I assume you know how to code I
assume that you know like the
fundamentals that you can program that
I'm not worried about that as much I'm
worried about how you are as a thinker
and not even like how you are as a
thinker but also how organized are you
as a thinker because I could potentially
interview someone that's very brilliant
but they might just kind of ramble on in
a way that I can't follow
and I just like even though I understand
they know that they're talking about I
just I need to think about it in the
context of a bigger team
and if they're not being straight to the
point and like being able to flesh out
in a way that's easy to follow their
points then that's not probably someone
I want to work with even if they're
brilliant so I think you know some of my
first comments is that I think you did a
great job at like not only explaining
your points but also like being able to
uh explain your points concisely I think
once you started having to write down
the Google Doc one thing I really
appreciated and I don't always see is
like you are very cautious to format it
nicely which is a big thing for me as a
reviewer it's like a small detail but I
think it goes a long way where it's like
it makes me it makes it easier for me to
understand things it makes it easier for
me to under like follow up on certain
points so like structure there is good
solid like formatting and all of that so
like
yeah all solid there I think overall
like I think a lot of just good
discussion I think you got to a lot of
points without me even having to prod to
that it's like you kind of got to some
of the like Crux of like oh these are
the features I want to do a uh you know
build a feature Vector of all this stuff
and like I had specific questions hoping
that you would get to feature vector and
stuff but you kind of just brought it up
on your own which was solid I think it
was a good use of like thinking out loud
like making sure that you're going
through your thought process and like
you know saying what you're thinking as
you're you know writing it out as you're
saying it just it allowed for more
discussion allowed me to just see how
you think well I definitely think that
like so because it's being put on
YouTube I definitely think that one
thing to mention that like people who
are kind of newer to Tech interviewing
and stuff like that like
I I don't think it's common knowledge if
you're new to the space to talk out loud
during these interviews like I I don't
think I think a lot of people just think
oh they asked me this question I just
need to give the answer no like you need
to
um
like what they really want to know is
how you think right not whether or not
you'll get to the right answer because
what an interview what an interviewer
hopefully should be doing is if you're
going on a completely wrong path kind of
guide you to the like right answer right
and I really enjoy interviews where it's
more like a conversation where I'm not
just talking to myself where I can
bounce ideas back and forth because that
also shows me like this is what it would
be like to work with this person on a
team
um so you really want to be able to
display how you think and how you arrive
at the answer rather than just saying an
answer and then justifying
it yeah
yeah definitely yeah I think that's
great to pull you know to bring up I
think that it is kind of weird it's kind
of different and new same thing with
like writing things down during an
interview like we use Google Docs here
but like traditionally if this was in
person like it'd be a whiteboard or
something I'm like I think some people
aren't prepared for that too so like
knowing that this might be what you have
to do but I think yeah speaking out loud
is super important
um let's see what other notes do I have
here so some like small details like
overall like from my perspective as an
interviewer like I thought you had a
solid performance like I I like good
performance like I'd be excited as an
interviewer to come out of that
interview like like this person hit the
main bullet points that I had so like
you know it would really come down to
what do the other candidates look like
but like definitely you know like
sometimes you come out of interview you
just immediately know like this
candidate was not right uh sometimes you
come out of it and you're like uh you
know maybe like I definitely came out of
this interview and I was like yeah that
was a solid performance like this person
knows what they're talking about they
think clearly so like good from there so
like I'll be nitpicky on things because
like overall good performance uh one
thing that you kind of did and It
ultimately was my next question but like
I would have liked to think a little bit
more discussion when I brought up the
data set you kind of skipped to the
model implementation
um
and so like I didn't stop you I didn't
pause you didn't bring you back because
that was the next question but just kind
of keeping in mind what the question was
at hand whereas you ended up focusing on
implementation which was important was
the next question but I think like I
would have liked to walk through that I
guess in a specific manner so small
nuanced detail like kind of annoying me
being annoying but like just something
to consider just keep in mind are you
answering the question that was asked
another detail this is kind of at the
end and there is like little things that
I'm like bringing up uh it's not like a
ton of I think things one thing at the
end I think I think it was good that you
mentioned like hey I don't have that
much information like knowledge in the
system side of things like you shouldn't
try to lie to your interviewer like I
think it's really impressive when
someone knows when to say hey I don't
know that much about that so like I
think it was good by like stating that
explicitly and not trying to like you
know spin off some information on random
cloud services that you actually don't
know much about because I might ask you
details about those and then you might
be like I have nothing so it could catch
you in a weird situation
I brought it up there was because you
asked a specific question about the
deployment of this right like yeah I
would never have said it myself like I
don't know that much about this but it
was literally just because you asked the
specific question that I did not know
the answer to that I brought this up and
like I don't think like I I think that
at least to me when I used to interview
people like to me it's it's okay if
somebody doesn't know something right
like what I want to see is that they're
teachable and that they can learn and
that they can think so yeah and I think
you bring up a good point though because
you're kind of the point is I asked you
about it and you said I don't know much
you don't want to call attention to
things that weren't brought up you don't
be like Oh I'm actually like a junior
engineer like I don't actually like know
that much code like don't bring up
things yeah
um I definitely see that uh sometimes in
like interviews that I do bringing up
things that they should bring up like be
very confident professional like know
your stuff fake it till you make it and
if they like bring up something specific
that you know you can't talk that much
about be honest but don't throw that out
on your own like let them bring it up so
some things that could improve on that
idea I think that it was good mentioning
of like you know obviously we're gonna
probably use a GPU probably gonna like
paralyze things I think one thing that
might have been interesting to say upon
that type of answer to dive into some of
the more technical details is I think
that
we would
maybe just explicitly kind of mentioning
like tokenizing maybe some of these
tweets and whatnot or whatever you want
to pass into the system
um but also I think a big thing that you
could have brought up was like batching
and just explicitly mentioned like you
probably don't want to take one tweet at
a time because that's gonna like
like if we think about all of glitter
as a parallel to Twitter obviously uh
there's so many tweets happening there's
so many potential bot accounts that if
we were trying to handle these on an
individual level like it would just be
in crazy and like intense processing so
we would need to like you know maybe we
have a window open for five seconds or
something that like collects a big batch
of these and we have our model set up in
such a way where it can process that
full batch and spit out that output and
then we have to parse that output so
that would be like I think one way to
improve that but I think it is on the
deployment side uh that is you know
maybe not your expertise but I think the
batching could have been something
interesting to bring up
um I'm trying to think of other specific
components I think the challenges I like
when I'm in an interview with two people
where one person's writing the notes and
one person's really leading the
interview uh because I think one thing
that's challenging sometimes is uh
writing those notes down as you're
trying to listen and let me see
I don't have too much like
I guess specific like criticism that I
wrote down I might like review
afterwards and provide additional things
other like positive notes you know for
people listening in whatnot
um like I I appreciated when we talked
about like you know anything that is
exciting to you I appreciate it that you
kind of like didn't just go oh chat GPT
you kind of like mentioned chat GPT
because I feel like that's right now
what I expect everyone to say so it was
nice to see some interest that was aside
from that
that was unique and different so like
you know you don't want to blend in with
every other candidate even if you want
to say something like chat GPT offer
something unique and different that
someone's going to Remember You by and I
think that talking about reinforcement
learning talking about you know
superhuman chess AI poker AI
spins up a more unique conversation
uh other I guess potential thing that
could have maybe improved things a bit
and maybe this was lack on my part of
like I call this a question was it
wasn't a question so it wasn't super
clear but I think there are some other I
think
um problems with Bots that you maybe
could have brought up I think you didn't
add that much new details and this
wasn't a data science question but from
my perspective as an interviewer I'm
going to challenge your domain knowledge
like if you're at a company I expect you
to know a bit about the company right
um so like some of the things I think
that
potentially I think there could have
been other I guess problems with Bots
that could have been brought up that
were kind of specifically unique and
different from things that I brought up
uh like one thing you could have even
mentioned is like it might hurt our
metrics we might you know if we have all
these Bots like it's hard for us to
report accurate metrics to people like
advertisers that you know might need
these accurate metrics to you know be
able to budget properly so that could
cause those problems down the road it's
outside the box it's different but it
might have been something interesting to
bring up just to show you're really
thinking about this uh other things like
you know Bots
and this kind of came up with the
following followers and who people
follow so it was kind of indirectly
answered this but like if Bots are
liking people's stuff really quickly on
like let's say there's a reply and maybe
a bot didn't reply to it maybe a human
replied but that human account had a
bunch of bots that immediately liked it
it might give undeserved prominence to
that reply uh tweet or whatnot as a pod
issue so you know these are small things
I'm poking at
um
but just it just takes things I guess to
improve further
uh yeah I don't think I have anything
else
yeah I don't have anything either all
right that's all we're going to cover in
this video If you enjoyed make sure to
throw this video a big thumbs up and
also subscribe to not miss any future
videos if you have questions about the
job interview process or have feedback
on this video make sure to leave a
comment down below huge shout out to
Kylie for joining and making this video
possible that's all I have for this
video as always thank you for supporting
the channel and until next time
[Music]